donc les sauver en face d'où je vous
disais en rentrant d'opérations revue
des troupes pour la nouvelle ministre
des armées florence parly en visite à la
section technique de satory elle a
rencontré des militaires rentrés du mali
du proche orient ou d'autres opérations
extérieures hélicoptères tigre
lance-roquettes drones de reconnaissance
plusieurs outils et véhicules ont été
présentés c'est à la fois comme on dire
une pédagogie technique sur l'ensemble
des moyens dont dispose l'armée terre
mais aussi un échange avec des soldats
qui ont vécu des épreuves et qui sont
les mieux à même au fond de commenter
les avantages et des inconvénients des
équipements qu'on leur profit les moyens
dont ils disposent doivent être
proportionnées au niveau d'engagement
parce que nous avons le devoir la
responsabilité d'être efficace est de
protéger nos soldats
le budget défense représente en 2010 est
plus de 37 milliards d'euros dont 8,6
milliards alloués à l'armée de terre ce
qui permet de financer de nouveaux
projets le programme scorpion c'est du
renouvellement de véhicules
c'est du renouvellement de systèmes
d'information et de commandement
et puis c'est aussi de la simulation
pour l'entraînement et pour faire
évoluer les procédés de combat
les besoins des militaires et des
programmes d'armement sont suivis ici à
la section technique de satory sous la
direction du général à rémy fouillant
les tests autour du programme scorpion
devrait se poursuivre les véhicules
devrait être opérationnel en 2018